a wealthy businessman with ties to two
US presidents may appear in court today
to face federal charges linked to
alleged sex trafficking 66 year-old
Jeffrey Epstein was arrested Saturday in
New Jersey after returning from Paris on
his private jet
well LNG is outside the Correctional
Facility where Epstein is being held
mullah from a private jet to a
Correctional Facility
we don't know about these charges well
good morning Tony what we know now is
that those charges are still currently
sealed but we do know that at least one
of the charges is related to sex
trafficking and Epstein is currently
being accused of underage sex abuse and
of course we should note that this is
not the first time that Epstein has been
linked to similar crimes Jeffrey Epstein
is now reportedly accused of molesting
dozens of minors he paid for massages in
New York in Florida from 2002 to 2005
the details of his indictment are
expected to be unsealed in federal court
in the Southern District of New York
today CBS News legal analyst Ricky
cleamen says that is not a good sign for
Epstein in the world of trial lawyers we
refer to the Southern District as the
most powerful law firm in the world they
do not go forward with a case unless
they have investigated it from top to
bottom and they are convinced that they
will get a conviction the well-connected
financier has admitted to sex abuse in
the past in 2008
Epstein pleaded guilty in Florida to
soliciting and procuring an underage
person for prostitution
court documents reveal the charges
stemmed from sexual activity with
privately hired masseuses that plea deal
landed Epstein in a Florida County Jail
for 13 months he had to register as a
sex offender but never faced federal
charges Brad Edwards an attorney
representing a young woman in the case
spoke to CBS News as Jericka Duncan in
December I don't think there's a person
in America who would ever look at the
facts of this case and believe that
there was even an actual punishment
Epstein has had several high-profile
friendships in the past President Bill
Clinton reportedly rode on Epstein's jet
more than two dozen times in the early
2000s in a 2002 interview then private
citizen Donald Trump called Epstein a
terrific
it has even said that he likes beautiful
women as much as I do
Trump said and many of them are on the
younger side we'll see where his
powerful friends or former friends go
once he appears in court later on today
we did reach out to Epstein's attorney
as well as the White House for comment
but have yet to hear back from either
now if these charges turn out to be sex
trafficking of minors or conspiracy to
engage in sex trafficking of minors
Epstein could face up to forty five
years in prison Anthony if he is
convicted mola thank you